COURTNEY: Hi everybody.
Thanks for coming.
Sorry that we're
starting a little late.
I would like to take
this opportunity
to introduce my neighbors,
Ian and Donna Mitroff.
They are the authors of "Fables
and the Art of Leadership:
Applying the Wisdom of Mr.
Rogers to the Workplace."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DONNA MITROFF: Good afternoon
and thank you for coming.
I'm Donna Mitroff.
We're going to spend
some time telling you
about how we came to know
Fred Rogers, how we came
to work with him, how
this book came to be.
But before we do, we have
a special surprise for you.
So if you'll just
wait one moment.
DAVID NEWELL: Speedy delivery.
Hello everybody,
speedy delivery.
My name is Mr. McFeely from
"Mr. Rogers' Neighborhood."
Hello.
Do you all remember McFeely?
[APPLAUSE]
Well, that's me.
I have a special
deliveries today.
In this suitcase, there are
some sayings on these papers.
And I thought I'd bring them by
and pass them all out to you.
So we'll start here.
You can take those.
And by the way, I started on
"Mr. Rogers' Neighborhood"
in 1967, before most of you
were born I think, right?
And it's been on
public television--
do you have enough in this row?
Here you go.
Here's two more.
And it showed on KQED,
and it's online now.
So I'm sure you know
how to get online.
And it's all over the
United States and in Canada.
And we have a new
show now called
"Daniel Tiger's Neighborhood,"
which is all animated.
And it's carrying on
Fred Rogers' legacy
along with the
Mitroffs, who are also
carrying on Mr. Rogers'
legacy in a different way.
But here I have more deliveries.
Can you a pass those out?
I have more.
And also, a little later,
I brought with me--
and the Mitroffs did a
special little addition.
They put Google down here.
And I can sign these.
So we'll do that a
little later, too.
And help yourself to
any of these cards.
Let me get more deliveries here.
I'll be right with
you, all right?
Oh, if anybody has any questions
about the Neighborhood just
ask me while we're doing this.
Do you all remember seeing it?
Have you all seen it?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Did Mr. Rogers do
all the voices for the puppets?
DAVID NEWELL: He did all
the voices for the puppets.
DONNA MITROFF: Oh, we're
going to tell you all of that.
DAVID NEWELL: Yes, you'll find
out more about that later.
But yes he did, except
a lot of other people
helped him maneuver them.
So, he only had two hands.
Thank you all for coming and put
the extras right back in here.
DONNA MITROFF: Are you going
to tell them to open them?
DAVID NEWELL: And I
also have, don't forget,
after we're all done
here, and we have--
DONNA MITROFF: Actually we're
going to do it right now,
David.
DAVID NEWELL: What?
DONNA MITROFF: Open
up your messages.
DAVID NEWELL: Oh, yes!
Open up your messages
because Donna has,
besides doing Google, if
anybody has on their message
a little red dot.
DONNA MITROFF: Red star.
Raise your hand.
DAVID NEWELL: Oh,
right off the bat.
DONNA MITROFF: Come
on up because you
are the lucky winners of
a free copy of this book.
[APPLAUSE]
We will be happy to
autograph these for you
after the session is over--
the presentation is over.
And any of you who decide
to buy the book, let us now.
We'll manage to get
the autograph to you.
We're pleased that
you came today.
DAVID NEWELL: And
then afterwards, I
can sign one of these,
or two of these,
or however many what
I have enough time.
So I can sign when
we're done here.
But I think you're ready
to do your presentation.
I will sit here and take
it all in, all righty?
Speedy delivery.
Oh yes, before we start, do
you think if I count to three,
you all can say speedy
delivery and that'll
be your cue to start.
So here we go one, two, three.
AUDIENCE: Speedy delivery.
DAVID NEWELL: OK Donna.
DONNA MITROFF: Thank you David.
Thank you.
David came all the
way from Pittsburgh
to share this with us today.
Pittsburgh--
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID NEWELL: Where
it's minus nine.
DONNA MITROFF:
Pittsburgh is the home
of "Mr. Rogers' Neighborhood."
It's also the home of WQED,
the Pittsburgh PBS station.
And that's where this
whole saga began for us.
Back in the 1970s--
actually it was in the late
'60s-- my husband and I moved
to Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania
where he took a job teaching at
the University of Pittsburgh.
And I did other things,
went to graduate school,
and did a Ph.D. in education.
And then eventually
went to work for WQED.
My first day on the job, I get
on the elevator and the person
riding up from the ground
floor to the third floor
with me is Mr. Rogers.
And I was, as they
say, verklempt.
So we started to talk and by
the end of riding three floors,
he invited me to come
over to his office.
And he said, maybe
there's something
that we can do together.
So I'm going to get into
telling you about that,
but that's my background
and how I met Fred.
I'm going to ask my
husband to tell you
a little bit about
his background.
IAN MITROFF: I have to
remember to talk through this.
I was born and raised
in San Francisco.
I did all my degrees
at UC Berkeley
when it was really,
really cheap.
So I went there from
freshman to Ph.D.
I got my Ph.D. In
engineering from Berkeley.
But while I was
getting my Ph.D.,
I took a three and
a half year minor,
which was unheard of, in
the philosophy of science,
never been done.
And the man who
taught me philosophy
was in the business school
at Berkeley, a great man.
And so he was a philosopher.
So it was only natural
when I got through,
because I loved
engineering, but I
didn't want to do
engineering anymore.
I went into a
business school where
I've taught
organization behavior.
All the people stuff that
they don't talk about
in engineering school.
So we were ripe
to do such a book.
Anyway, Donna go on.
DONNA MITROFF: So that's a us
back in the '70s, lots of hair,
fewer wrinkles, fewer pounds.
And take the next slide.
I moved over to
WQED the late '70s.
And that's me standing out
in front of X the Owl's tree.
How many of you watched
Mr. Rogers at any time?
Wow!
That's pretty amazing.
So anyway this show is one
of the longest running shows
on public television
ever, 35 continuous years.
And it is still available.
As David said, you can
still see it online.
Lots of parents find it and
watch it with their kids
today because it's still
speaks to you today.
So after my meeting with
Fred Rogers in the elevator,
I went by his office.
And we started talking
about what we could do.
I was an educator,
there as director
of educational services.
And he said, I wish
we could do more
to help people-- parents,
caregivers, preschool teachers,
whoever's using it-- help
them understand that there are
some lessons, not just watch
the show, but something to do.
So we set about developing what
we call the plan and play book.
I was watching the shows
then writing lesson plans
for what to do after
you watch the show.
And that book became sort of the
basis for Public Television's
Ready to Learn Project,
and started a relationship
with Fred and his
company, including
David, that has gone on since
the late '60s, '70s, and exists
even today where I'm still
involved with the Fred Rogers
company, and with the
Fred Rogers memorial
scholarship, which is
our effort to continue
with his legacy in
children's media.
Who was Fred Rogers?
How many of you think you
know how Fred Rogers was?
What a unique person he was.
Do you know that
he was a puppeteer?
He did most of the puppets.
Do you know that
he wrote the music?
He played the music.
Do know that he wrote
most of the scripts?
Do you know that he had advanced
degrees in child development?
So it didn't just come
from his imagination.
It came from his heart, and
his soul, and his training.
So there's so much
embedded in the stories
that he told, way beyond.
He was not a typical performer.
He wasn't an actor.
In fact, David
will share with you
some of the stories
about how reluctant he
was to do things other than
keep building a great show.
So the show went
on the air in '67?
DAVID NEWELL: It went on
air February 18, 1968.
We started taping in '67.
DONNA MITROFF: So on the
air five times a week,
every week, for an
entire 35 years.
So there's a lot of Mr.
Rogers embedded in your minds.
And its back there.
And what we're
going to do is help
you bring those lessons
back forward to today.
IAN MITROFF: Let me
just add one thing.
Probably most people don't
know that Fred was an ordained
Presbyterian minister.
And he looked at the state
of children's television
as it was at the time--
mostly like throwing pies
in people's faces-- and
his ministry literally
became to make
television for children
what it should and must become.
And that really was
this lifelong goal.
DONNA MITROFF: Now,
his major show was "Mr.
Rogers' Neighborhood." and
"Mr. Rogers' Neighborhood"
was made up of these
two different segments.
You remember how he would
come in, put on his sweater,
change his shoes.
He did that because
kids like routine.
It gets to be very
comfortable for you.
But then he would go into
his own home, on the set,
and there would be
many experiences where
he would bring people
in and they would talk.
He would take you
out to visit places
that people love, like the
visit to the Crayon Factory.
Kids play with crayons.
They want to know how
do crayons get made?
So he would take
people to real places
and do documentary
footage in a real setting.
And one of the
highlights of his show
was always the Neighborhood
of Make Believe.
He'd send that little
trolley around the track.
And this was done
very deliberately.
So you're leaving
the real world,
and you're going
into a neighborhood
of make believe where
anything can happen.
And the Neighborhood
of Make Believe
was populated by puppets
that everyone came to know.
Here's just a few of them King
Friday, Queen Sarah Saturday,
Lady Elaine Fairchilde, Lady
Aberlin, and Daniel Tiger.
Daniel tiger, the one who is
now the star of the new show.
Many others in the
Neighborhood of Make Believe,
and some live
performers, never Fred.
You never saw him in the
Neighborhood of Make Believe
because he was real.
But you saw some of the other
people as live performers.
David was there.
You would see David in the
Neighborhood of Make Believe.
And in that Neighborhood
of Make Believe
is where we found this richness
of information and ideas
that we want to share with you.
So what began to happen
as-- after Fred died,
I was involved with the
Academy of Television Arts
and Sciences, the ones
who do the Emmy's.
And we decided there
that we give a tribute
to Mr. Rogers for the industry
in Southern California.
So we set about-- I was
one of the producers
of that show--
putting this together.
And in doing so, I was
re-reading Fred's materials,
looking at the shows, and I
kept coming home and telling
my husband, who was a professor
of management organizational
behavior, much of what goes into
making organizations work until
he said--
IAN MITROFF: When Donn a
was sharing the lessons,
the lessons were more
profound than you
get in most management books.
I mean, they're not devoid
of lessons, but they're dry.
They're didactic.
And the idea that
took shape for Donna
and I is that we began
to go back and read
some of the major
fables the were
on the Neighborhood
of Make Believe.
And the idea that
crystallized is
that the fables were in effect
little mini business cases.
That King Friday, for
example, is the autocratic CEO
and you can begin to identify
the other characters.
And the idea said, Look
let's try and teach
organizational behavior
through fables and stories.
Why fables and stories?
Because that's the primary
way that human beings
have communicated
with one another
since the dawn of civilization,
not with formulas,
not with textbooks,
but with good stories.
We were lucky to get to Palgrave
McMillan-- the next slide.
DONNA MITROFF: But wait I
want to have the next slide.
IAN MITROFF: We
were lucky to get--
DONNA MITROFF: A
contributer to this idea
that there are lessons
here for grownups
was at this tribute
to Fred Rogers.
One of the people who
spoke was Anne Sweeney.
Some of you might have heard--
Anne was here recently doing
a talk to women's leadership
in Silicon Valley.
And you see she's got a
very high level position.
And when Anne came
on to the stage
and talked about what she
learned from Fred Rogers
that she still uses as
a high level executive,
it helped to crystallize
our feeling that there
are other people out there who
learned things from Fred that
stayed with them, not just
as my husband always says,
he helped you as a child, he
can help you as a grown up.
So we went on and
we found a publisher
and we pulled together
these three principles.
Fred's lessons
were more profound
than traditional methods of
management and leadership
training.
He taught through
stories and fables.
Those who watched
as children are now
in middle and upper
management positions.
And here you are.
You watched him
when you were a kid
and now you're advancing
through your careers.
IAN MITROFF: Can we go
through to the next slide?
Let me tell you what
crystallized is we went back
and read the fables.
Seven principles
emerged early on.
And those are the
seven principles.
Go to the next slide.
And each of them is illustrated
through a direct quote
from Fred and an accompanying
fable in the book.
And we're going to read just
through the fables because
of time later.
So the first one, connect.
You can read it.
"A person can grow
to his or her
fullest capacity only
in mutually caring
relationships with others."
Next please.
Concern.
One of the misperceptions
of Fred Rogers
is that he was thoroughly
no rules, anything goes.
That's not true at all.
I think one of the best sayings
that we culled out from Fred
is, "Setting rules," good
rules, not harsh rules,
"is one of the primary
ways in which we
show our love for others."
Now, in a good organization
you do it with your employees,
not didactically, not
necessarily autocratically.
Next one please.
"Play is the expression
of creativity,
and I," Fred believes, "is at
the very root of our ability
to learn to cope and
become whatever we may be."
Next please.
Communication.
"In times of stress,"
especially in stress,
"the best thing we
can do for each other
is listen with our
ears and our hearts
to be assured that
our questions are just
as important as our answers."
I don't need to tell you that
it's obviously broken down
on our political life.
One thing I ought to
say, we have no illusions
about what
organizations are today.
We're talking about an
ideal, which if we practice,
it would hopefully improve
our organizations as they are.
Next one please.
Consciousness.
"Take good care of that part of
you where your best dreams come
from, that invisible part
of you," Fred was spiritual,
"that allows you to look upon
yourself and your neighbor
with delight."
Next one.
Maybe go back to
the previous one.
There is some growing
recognition, believe it or not,
in business schools and
schools of management,
that spirituality at work
plays a core role in our lives.
I was fortunate to write
one of the earliest
books on spirituality at
work, and I went around
and interviewed people
and what spirituality
meant to them during their day.
For example, how
much of themselves
they could bring to work?
Next one, please.
Courage.
"One of the greatest paradoxes,"
about life, "about omnipotence
is that we need feel
it early in life,
and lose it early
in life, in order
to achieve a healthy, realistic,
yet exciting sense of potency
later on."
Next one, please.
Community.
"All of us, at some
time or other,"
I might say even
constantly, "need help.
Whether we're giving or
receiving help, each one of us
has something valuable
to bring to the world.
That's one of the
things that connects us
as neighbors-- in
our own way, each one
is a giver and a receiver."
I mean if we could
summarize the book,
how could we turn
our organizations
at best into caring
neighborhoods.
Next one, please.
OK, here the seven
fables that we picked out
to illustrate each
of these principles.
And the fables just ring.
In fact, they're really
in your consciences.
Now, we're just going
to talk about two
of them because of time.
So Donna you ah-- We're going
to start with "Planet Purple"
and we'll talk about "The
Bass Violin Festival."
DONNA MITROFF: So
I'm going to give you
a brief reading
of the story just
to take you back
to remember what
happened in the story
of "Planet Purple."
And then you just think about
this as a mini case study,
but Ian's going to
break it down or you
tell how it teaches
lessons for management
and for organizations.
The story of "Planet Purple."
"On a space mission,
Lady Elaine Fairchilde
discovered a new planet.
A place where
everything was purple.
Everyone had the
same purple home.
The sky was purple.
The cars, chairs, and
streets were purple.
And there were the
same purple trees.
In addition, all of
the boys and girls
were named Paul and Pauline.
And every single panda
was call Purple Panda.
Everyone on Planet Purple ate
purple pumpernickel pudding,
and talked in the
same monotonous voice.
And for years and
years, everybody
dreamed the same dreams
and had the same hopes.
"When Lady Elaine Fairchilde's
bright green space
ship landed on Planet
Purple and she stepped out
in her white astronaut suit,
the Planet Purple people
ran and hid in fear.
But one Paul, and one
Pauline, and one purple panda
didn't run and hide.
They stayed around to look
at this curious creature.
Lady Elaine, whose favorite
color happened to be purple,
was very intrigued
by this planet.
She liked seeing
everything in purple
and she liked not
having to remember
a lot of different names.
"After exploring the
planet, she decided
to fly back to tell
everyone back home
about this new planet.
Lady Elaine didn't know that
Paul, Pauline, and Purple Panda
were watching her and
decided to follow her.
"The Planet Purple
way to travel is just
by thinking and thinking alone.
All you have to do is
think that you're someplace
and instantly you'll be there.
So Paul, Pauline,
and Purple Panda
thought about Lady Elaine, where
she was and immediately they
arrived in the Neighborhood
of Make Believe.
"They could hardly believe
what they saw and heard.
Everything and
everybody was different.
Purple Panda was so
excited that he sat down
in the first rocking
chair he saw.
He rocked, and he
rocked, and rocked,
and then he remembered one
of Planet Purple's laws.
Anyone who rocks
on a rocking chair
may not live in Planet Purple.
But now it was too late.
He could never go back.
Paul and Pauline wanted
to explore this new place
before going back.
So they went everywhere.
They looked.
They listened.
They smelled.
They touched.
They felt the colors,
They smelled the smells.
And they felt the
different feelings.
"One day Paul fell
down and hurt himself.
And he felt something wet
trickling down his cheek.
A rabbit asked him
why he was crying?
Paul had to ask
what crying meant.
No one ever cried
on Planet Purple.
When the rabbit heard that Paul
had never cried before he said,
you've just started to live.
"Finally, Paul and
Pauline decided
to return to Planet Purple.
So they use the
Planet Purple way
to travel, thought about being
there and they were back home.
They told the other Pauls
and Paulines about the place
where Lady Elaine lived.
How everything is so
different and nobody
is exactly the same
as anyone else.
They even told about
Purple Panda rocking
in the rocking
chair, and everyone
knew he'd broken the law
and could never come back.
"The other Pauls and
Paulines didn't like the idea
that everything and everybody
should be different.
Paul and Pauline helped them
imagine colors, sound, smells,
feelings.
It took a long time to
change their planet.
And some people didn't
like some things,
and other people didn't
like other things,
but everybody ended
up saying it was
still better than being
the same all the time.
They even changed the
law about rocking chairs
so Purple Panda could come
back any time he wanted.
"The citizens of Planet
Purple held a celebration
to announce that the
name of Planet Purple
would be changed to Planet
Purple Fairchilde in honor
of the one who helped
them become different.
Both Lady Elaine and Purple
Panda came to the celebration.
The End."
Now just think about it for
a minute as a business case.
I think you'll be surprised.
Go ahead Ian.
IAN MITROFF: Here are some
of the principal lessons
of Planet Purple translated into
the implications for business.
In many ways the fable
is about waking up
from an overly rigid,
hierarchical organization
to a more equitable
organization.
Let me give you some things that
aren't up there on the slide.
Miss Fairchilde,
who could well be
an executive VP, her
challenging assignment
is explore different models for
the design of her organization.
She comes across
Planet Purple, Inc.
that has a beautiful simplicity,
but by just coming and asking
questions, she's disturbed
the status quo profoundly.
When she comes across the
organization, as I said,
it's an old fashioned, overly
repressed organization.
The employees are virtually in
a state of suspended, repressed
psychological and
emotional development.
There's a lack of integration
between thinking and feelings.
That's one of the main
underlying themes of the story.
In effect, the people
live in a cocoon.
Planet Purple organizations,
as we well know,
virtually have a single
measure of performance.
All that matters
is the bottom line.
In contrast, Planet
Prism organizations
are a model of diversity.
Everything is different.
The King even enjoys--
the King Friday
is the stand in for the
autocratic CEO-- even
enjoys talking with employees.
Yes, he's still in
charge because we're
not against hierarchy, per se.
That's not the point.
But the point about the
Planet Prism organization,
their primary goal is do
no harm to the planet,
and make products that serve
authentic human needs, not
false needs.
Let's go on to the next fable.
DONNA MITROFF:
OK, the Next story
is "The Bass Violin
Festival." and this story
we have paired with our topic of
one of our C's for creativity.
So listen to this
one and think of how
the lessons that this
has about creativity
in your organizational life.
"One day in the Neighborhood
of Make Believe,
King Friday receives a
message from the mayor
of an adjoining locality
saying that she would
like to arrange a festival that
involves all of the surrounding
neighborhoods.
King Friday likes that idea
and immediately proclaims
that it'll be a bass
violin festival.
Chuck Aber, one of his subjects,
points out that he, the King,
is the only one who actually
plays the bass violin.
Undaunted by this, King
Friday says, oh, so I am.
"King Friday's
subjects are pleased
at the prospect of a joint
neighborhood festival,
but quite taken aback that
it will be just a bass violin
festival, and that they
must all participate.
Lady Aberlin is
especially disconcerted
when King Friday presents
her with a bass violin
and tells her it's
a fine instrument.
It was made by an
excellent instrument maker.
She acknowledges that it may
be a very special bass violin.
However, she says, I cannot
play the bass violin.
Just because a person
has a fine instrument
doesn't mean that he can
play that instrument well.
King Friday simply tells her,
go on keep on practicing.
"Over the next few
days, the subjects
meet to share their frustration
about being required
to perform a skill
they do not have.
One day Lady Elaine Fairchilde
arrives and tells them
she has a solution
to the problem."
Remember Lady Elaine?
She's the outspoken, gutsy one.
"She produces her
accordion, the instrument
that she plays very well, and
it is covered by a false front
to make it look
like a bass violin.
She tells them that
now she's going
to play the bass
violin for them.
They watch and
listen in amazement.
Lady Aberlin then points
out that, you're actually
playing your accordion.
Lady Elaine acknowledges
it is an accordion.
But since it looks
like a bass violin,
it could work for The
Bass Violin Festival.
"Lady Elaine's clever
solution gives the others
an important idea.
They could all think of ways
to make what they do look
like bass violins so that could
contribute to the festival.
Lady Aberlin knows how to dance.
So she decides to dance
with the bass violin.
Miss Paulifficate puts
on a bass violin costume
and plays at being
a bass violin.
Keith and Michael Jones
make bass violin puppets
who will perform a bass
violin conversation.
Another neighbor dresses up as a
special flower, a bass vio-let.
And yet another one
decides to write and recite
a poem about the bass violin.
"In the midst of
their excitement,
they realize that
King Friday needs
to be told what
they're going to do.
They become a little worried
that he may not like the news.
Lady Aberlin confides
to Daniel Tiger.
And Daniel says,
the best thing to do
is tell the King the truth,
that not everybody can learn
to play the bass
violin so they're
going to do other
things with it, things
that they can do well.
With the support
and encouragement
of all her friends Lady Aberlin
tells King Friday the truth.
He listens to the
plan and concludes
that these are very clever
ideas and perhaps this festival
could turn out to be
something special.
And indeed it is.
The very, very
special Bass Violin
Festival where
everyone contributes
with his or her own
special talent."
IAN MITROFF: OK, let me go over
the lessons briefly of "The
Bass Violin" and it is really
one of my favorite stories out
of Fred's.
That number one, technology--
particularly talking
to a technology company-- is
never a substitute for skill.
The fact that King
Friday is an expert,
you can't assume that
everybody else will take to it
and become an expert.
Number two, technology
often increases our fears.
We all know that.
It makes us feel painfully
aware of our shortcomings,
so increases anxiety.
Three, often we're afraid.
Indeed the more we are, we
project our fears on others.
See for all we
know in the fable,
King Friday may have
given the assignment
to see if his employees-- take
the metaphor employees-- would
break out and become creative.
Because the fable, in many
ways, is about re-framing,
taking the initial
assignment, which
may be impossible
to solve on its own.
Creativity forces us to
confront our deepest fears.
Will we be foolish and
laughed at if we expose
or ideas and feelings
to the world?
To be creative we
have to be childlike,
without being childish.
Last thing let me
talk to you about.
Those of you who've taken
courses in statistics
early on learn about two errors,
type one and type two errors.
I won't go through them.
If you've taken a class,
you know what it is.
There's an error that is
virtually never talked about,
which is most fundamental.
It's the type three error.
The type three error is solving
the wrong problem precisely.
I'm sure you can all
connect with that.
Solving the wrong
problem precisely.
To know that we're not solving
the wrong problem precisely,
what we have to do is have
at least two different ways
of looking at a problem.
If you have only
one alternative,
that's really a
set up that you're
going to solve
the wrong problem.
And that's really what
the fable is about.
And that's what we
talk about in the book.
Let me go on to the next slide.
DONNA MITROFF: You can
imagine that if they
had taken the
assignment directly
and all tried to learn to
play the bass violin in time
for the festival,
they would have
been very successful at solving
the wrong problem precisely.
They would have committed
the error of the third kind.
IAN MITROFF: OK,
we're near the end
here where our time with you.
But I'm just going to
talk about very briefly
what the rest of the book does.
We apply the fables and we
bring in some topics that
are both talked about and
really not talked about
in business schools.
For example, life skills.
Ellen Galinsky who has gone
around the country and talk
with investigators who
study young children.
What are the key skills that
kids need to learn early
and we need to emphasize them
throughout our whole lives.
I've worked with a friend
who's developed a marvelous
instrument for getting how to
help people handle conflict.
Defense mechanisms.
One of the earliest
discoveries of Freud.
If the defense
mechanisms are high,
like denial, you can't do any
of this in an organization.
Personality styles.
We talk about the Myers Briggs.
Number five, I've worked my
pretty much my whole career
as one of the developers
of crisis management.
Years ago, starting with
the first Tylenol poisoning,
I moved into the field
of crisis management.
And lastly, I don't know
how many of you have ever
heard of attachment theory.
But it's one of the most
profound theories about how
we build trust early
on in our lives.
Attachment theory
provides really
the basic models of trust
that go back literally
from the day we are born.
The interactions with
our primary caregivers.
So the point about
the book, I guess,
Donna said it before,
but let me say it again,
if we had to summarize
the book in one line
it would be that, Fred helped
you when you were a child,
he can help you when
you're an adult.
Because the lessons of Fred,
the stories, are so finely hewn,
they're so finely
crafted that they really
reverberate throughout
our entire lives.
Now, we were lucky to find a
publisher, Palgrave McMillan,
an academic publisher, and
they started a new series
to teach organizational
behavior.
They had people,
such as us, write
books that would teach
organizational behavior
through stories and fables.
And we were lucky to be one of
the first books in the series.
DONNA MITROFF: Talk
about the book.
How they positioned
it and market it.
And it is a textbook.
IAN MITROFF: It's a
supplementary textbook
because it's not out
of the mainstream.
Hopefully, telling
stories in fables
will move more in
the mainstream,
how we teach business.
DONNA MITROFF: But
I just want to say
what you'll see if you read
the book, it's in three parts.
Part one, is we just
tell you the stories
and we ask you to
think about them.
Part two, we go back and analyze
each of these seven stories
in some detail.
And then in part three, is
the real academic application.
And that's where we bring
in all of these other areas
and we provide exercises.
And we know the book is
being adopted by some faculty
members around the
country and being
used in management
classes, but not enough.
And it's the kind
of thing that if you
wanted to start a group
of your own, read the book
and talk about it, the ideas
are there for how you can.
IAN MITROFF: But at this
point we need to stop.
We have a few questions for you.
And I'm sure you have questions.
One of Fred's, we think,
profound ways in which you
would end, even start a meeting
was said, close your eyes.
So everybody close your eyes.
And think about who is
the person or persons that
were most impactful
on your career.
I think the way Fred put
it, willed you in to being.
And the second thing we
would ask you to think about
is, what have you heard
today that you can carry back
directly into your
jobs to make your life
and the life of your
colleagues better.
We'll take a few seconds.
Keep your eyes closed.
OK, floor is open for you.
Any questions, comments.
DONNA MITROFF: Any
thoughts that came
to you during that
eyes closed moment.
We'd like for this
to be a conversation.
So anyone who wants to
say anything about a story
like this being applied to your
organization, or any thoughts.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I found it fascinating that
the Planet Purple people felt,
or believe, that they could
travel just by thinking.
And what I brought
back from that is,
I tend to be an ideas person.
But if you really want
to carry an idea through,
you have to be
committed to the steps
that it takes to
bring it to fruition.
You can't just think about
it and say, it's done.
DONNA MITROFF: That's very good.
That's very good.
Very interesting.
IAN MITROFF: Well, I mean,
what you said-- yeah,
I'm primarily a
thinking person too,
going through engineering,
philosophy of science.
But the point is that we
don't sell ideas alone just
through the ideas.
We sell them through stories.
I mean think about the leaders
who were most effective.
Whether you like President
Clinton or Obama,
they have a story.
Even George W. Bush, OK,
I didn't agree with him,
but he had a story.
And he was effective that way.
So the most effective
leaders have
a way of encapsulating
the lessons
into something that moves us.
Because ideas alone,
Yeah, they're necessary,
but they're not sufficient.
And that's the point
why we did the book.
DONNA MITROFF: And
the other point
of the thinking way of traveling
is that you only use your mind.
You leave your body.
You don't use it.
You can't do that.
You have to integrate
your mind, and your body,
and your spirit to really
accomplish anything.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering
about the process
of building stories.
Because there's a very
creative aspect to it,
but there's also the taking
what you want to get across
and communicating
it effectively.
And sometimes you can
be very, very creative
and no one understands
what you're talking about.
Other times, you could be
very clear on what you're
talking about, but the story
is banal or are not compelling.
And I'm wondering if you guys
have any insight in terms
of Mr. Rogers' process on how
he got from what he wanted
to get across and into a story.
IAN MITROFF: David do you have
any idea what the process was
that Fred went through?
DAVID NEWELL: It was based a
lot on letters from the public.
This is not exactly
answering your question,
but the most requested topic
we ever had over the years
was from people
talking about Fred
helping their
families with divorce.
And we got so many-- and this
is going back maybe 20 years--
and Fred didn't
know how to do it.
And finally-- he had a
professional child development
expert with him all the
time-- and they finally
came up with a concept.
And we did a whole
week on divorce.
And the one thing
that Fred wanted
to get across to children was
that it's not their fault.
So it evolved like that.
Another time, much
more light hearted,
there was a time when we
did a week on superheroes.
I had seen an article where a
child thought he was Superman,
put a towel around his neck,
and jumped off a building,
and killed himself.
And that was going on.
And so we went to
"The Incredible Hulk,"
watching it being filmed.
Remember "The Incredible Hulk?"
We went to Universal Studios
and showed that this is pretend.
Here's this person
getting into his makeup.
He broke it down.
And Fred thought that way.
He wanted to demystify a
lot of different things.
But does that answer
your question?
The creativity came a lot
of times from the public.
But a lot, like "The
Bass Violin Festival."
it came from Fred's
love of music, too.
He used that as a metaphor of
sorts to get that point across.
So it came from many
different places.
Do you have anything to add?
IAN MITROFF: One other
response, the kind of philosophy
I studied was really in the
school of pragmatism, William
James.
If you read the opening
pages of "Pragmatism", one
of William James' key
works, he tells a story,
it's a brief story
about a working man, who
had been out of work for a year.
He finally got a job
in physical labor.
But he was hurt.
He was weak.
He couldn't do it
so we came home.
He killed his family
and he killed himself.
And William James-- you know it
was ripped from the headlines--
and William James asked
what does philosophy
have to say to this?
If it has nothing to say,
it has nothing to say.
And so the point
is, you know, I mean
I've written scores of books.
You've got wherever you
find the story-- I'm
working on a book
with my in-law,
the father of my son-in-law.
And he's a retired
bio-stat guy from Stanford.
And we're talking about
writing a book on health
for the public, the kind
of concerns they have.
He worked with Michael DeBakey
and I keep saying, Abe, we've
got to crystallize the stories.
For every point that
we want to make,
there has to be an
accompanying story.
See one of things they didn't
say earlier about fables
and why we went with fables.
The reason why
fables reverberate,
they're stereotypes, but
the good guys and bad guys
are clearly drawn.
That's why we were
drawn to fables.
And the moral lessons are clear.
Now you get into stereotype.
You can exaggerate.
But that's what fables do.
So they cut through
all the stuff there,
and they make it come to life.
They're human.
And you don't get
that, you know?
I mean come on.
I'm an academic.
I've been in the academic
world for my whole life.
You're not rewarded
for doing that.
And there's so like all the
idea stuff, that's necessary.
But it's not sufficient to
get it out here to the world.
And that's why we wrote the book
because what a challenge for us
to do what you were asking.
Anybody else?
We have a few minutes.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's a great concept
to apply these lessons
to the workplace.
Of course, you guys actually
shared the workplace
with Fred Rogers.
I'm curious what was
that workplace like.
Was it any different?
I loved your story of
actually closing your eyes.
Are there more
examples like that?
DONNA MITROFF: It was chaotic.
It was always
bubbling and jumping
and things were happening and
things didn't get done on time.
Some recognition up here.
But there was always that
underlying current of we
know where we're going.
This is about
something important.
And that's the thing that kept
everybody coming back together.
Now the day-to-day stories?
David has piles of those.
DAVID NEWELL: I was in
every one of the tapings.
We did over thousands of
tapings and I was in them a lot.
And the one time that you could
tell-- Fred was a musician--
and you could tell
when he was frustrated.
He would never yell or throw
a sneaker across the floor.
He would go to the piano.
And when we sat
down at the piano
and would play the piano
that was his-- anger
came out through his
fingers or his frustrations.
And that's how he dealt with it.
And people would
follow that, too.
They knew that Fred
was saying something
to them when the
piano would start.
And after every taping
Fred had a tradition,
he'd go to the piano
and-- you're all
too young to know up it, but in
the movie theaters in the '40s
and '50s, they had newsreels.
And there was a news
reel that started out
with a rooster crowing.
It as the RKO Warner
Brothers News,
something that had a
very distinct theme.
Da, da, da dat da da.
It's like playing "And That's
All Folks" from Looney Tunes.
He would sit down and play that,
and we knew the day was done.
But Fred talked through music.
DONNA MITROFF: He talked
through music, yeah.
IAN MITROFF: One thing
that I do remember--
I'll get the story a little
bit wrong, not exactly.
I remember watching Fred one
time on the old "Johnny Carson
Show."
I don't how many of you watched
the old "Johnny Carson Show."
And Fred was talking
about what he did.
Johnny, they were
engaged in conversation.
And Fred was talking about
the importance of children's
feelings, and somebody
in the audience guffawed.
And Fred looked at that
person steely cold and said,
that's not funny.
And I remember that
because, again,
to think that OK, he was
bubbly and light all the time.
No way.
I mean, yes, this
was a spiritual,
a really good person.
But the things that
he didn't have strong
values-- In fact, we
talked about that.
This was more than a
one time occurrence.
I know when I've
been involved-- I'm
in a research
center at Berkeley--
and we have people come in and
they'll talk about feelings--
because it's a center about
crises and everything--
they'll talk about warm fuzzies.
I have to bite my tongue
and I can't always do it.
And say, don't you
insult feelings that way.
You don't do that with a kid.
DONNA MITROFF: Or with anybody.
IAN MITROFF: Or with anybody.
DONNA MITROFF: Because
you bring those feelings
with you no matter what.
And they have to be dealt
with no matter where you are,
no matter what age you are,
they have to be dealt with.
IAN MITROFF: One of
the things I found
when I did my book on
spiritually was called
"The Spiritual Audit
of Corporate America,"
that one of the things
that people talk about what
spirituality meant
to them at work
was how much of
their whole person
they could bring to work.
Could they only bring
their head, but not
your their feelings, their
heart, and their body.
And so the whole point is, we're
fragmented enough in our lives
that they didn't want to be
further fragmented at work.
Or to go home and repair
for all the beating
up that they took
during the week.
And then go home and repair
so they could come back
and take another
40, 50 hours more.
So the organizations that quote
have a spiritual bent, whatever
you want to call it, get
more of the whole person.
They don't exploit that person.
And they get more
of the creativity.
That's why all of these
fables really reverberate.
OK, I think we
have time for more.
DONNA MITROFF: Do we
any time Courtney?
COURTNEY: One more question.
DAVID NEWELL: Can I follow
up with what you asked?
This just shows
Fred's sense of humor.
He had a wonderful
sense of humor.
The crew knew this.
You know how he changed
his shoes and sneakers
and put his--?
At the very end of
the program, they
snuck in a pair
of smaller shoes.
And he put his shoe on
by talking and winding
his foot into it.
And he couldn't do it.
And you heard the
crew started to laugh.
He wore a size 10, and
they gave him size 8.
You can't tell just
by looking at it.
And he thought
that was so funny.
And it Dick Clark showed
it on his outtake reels.
Just one other quicky.
You know those blow up dolls?
This is something that nobody's
ever told anyone, but I will.
[LAUGHTER]
They said, OK, Fred, we're
going to start to show.
He came in, sang the
song, put the sweater on,
went to the cupboard,
and there was a blow up
doll hanging in the closet.
And it startled him.
So he pulled it out and
started dancing with it.
DONNA MITROFF: That was
a creative solution.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID NEWELL: But
that was an outtake
that we never let
out of our hands.
But you now know about it.
But the point I'm saying is
that he had a sense of humor.
And it goes back
to feelings, too.
He wasn't mad and stomped
out and said, OK, you're
all suspended.
That didn't work with Fred.
AUDIENCE: Just a comment.
There's been a lot of
attention in the media
lately about women taking
on management positions
and doing very well,
exercising more,
kind of, masculine management
type characteristics.
But the thing that
I love about Fred,
and especially looking
back because I never
would have picked this up as a
child, but as an adult, is he
was one of the first men who
was comfortable exhibiting
more feminine characteristics.
As a man, being in
touch with feelings.
DONNA MITROFF: And he also
created Lady Elaine Fairchilde.
And she--
AUDIENCE: There you go.
DONNA MITROFF: --was
that futuristic woman,
who wasn't afraid to stand up.
There are other
stories in our book
where she was the one
who stood up to the CEO
and said, don't ask me to do
something if you don't tell me
why I'm going to do it.
I mean that's pretty
masculine but that was--
IAN MITROFF: Suzanne,
I have to talk
about, you raised something
that's really important.
One of the things about
Fred, which is sad,
is that many men
are uncomfortable.
So you have all
these urban legends
that underneath he was
tattooed, and he was a seal,
and all that kind of
stuff because the reason
is you couldn't take that there
would be a man who would openly
talk about feelings, and
wouldn't be a effeminate--
or whatever the derogatory
term of the day-- and we
know all that kind of stuff.
So they had to project onto Fred
their fears and anxiety to make
him into something
that he wasn't.
He was masculine.
But I mean if you talk about,
if you go to Jung, where
you have both the feminine
and the masculine archetypes.
They are in every one of
us, but they're not always
equally developed.
And we're not always equally
comfortable in displaying
both of them.
That's another thing that
when you look at the story.
The story was the whole feeling,
was the whole the persona,
of Fred himself.
DONNA MITROFF: I think
we need to wrap it up.
We wanted to share with
you we have a website,
you can learn more about it.
And also the next one
has our email addresses.
IAN MITROFF: We also want
to thank our publicist
Rina Neiman, who helped
us put this together.
And our uh--
DONNA MITROFF: So you're
invited to be in touch with us
by email.
Nina has put together
the Twitter page for us.
Are you familiar
with this picture?
Of my, this picture is
just-- That's what happens.
And now it's happening to David.
People who can't touch
Fred, will come up to David
and just grab this
face because they
want they want to get close.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you
so much Ian, Donna, David.
David will be over
there in the green booth
to sign autographs
for his pictures.
Thank you guys for coming.
[APPLAUSE]